um I was skeptical about this whole
conference to be honest I
basically anything Shawn wants to do
turns out to be interesting and I'm
interest but this one was to me way too
philosophical in its concept I thought
and I was ready to be surprised if
anything would really come out of it
other than a lot of very general talk
where I'm ending up is still with my
reverence to science but feeling that
feeling that there are topics which I
was concerned about with science because
we weren't getting answers and I've come
to the conclusion that there is a point
where philosophy is basically subducting
under science where it's it's convenient
to throw those topics the philosophy
whether it's many worlds or anthropic or
what which at least on a temporary basis
philosophy could look at work at and
maybe ultimately throw useful ideas back
to science which will help turn those
some back into scientific principals and
vice versa so to this Cole I'm getting
more reverence for philosophy than I had
before although I don't want to spend a
lot of time reading it except for Dan's
books which I do read them but I will
say I mentioned this to Shawn this has
fundamentally changed my life as it
turns out because one of the subjects
that I was very interested in because it
feeds into my background and what I've
been working on which is the criminal
justice system and it has really changed
my mind because even though I think it's
possible I might be among the most
hardcore naturalist here and I don't
know if there's free will I don't know
if there's consciousness and to me at
least we prove it to me nonetheless it's
clear that we got to work with these
concepts in society and act as if they
exist otherwise it's gonna be very
complicated for society I don't think we
should be patronizing and hold back our
reverence for naturalism at the same
time I think we could work with concepts
of volition and we need to in terms of
our justice system the way society works
I think we need to radically overhaul
the criminal justice system and I've
been thinking that I am even more
determined than ever to work on that I'm
not sure there's a big difference
between how we should treat people who
are criminally insane and people who are
criminally guilty because I think that
there are concerns about free will and
about volition and and I've already been
thinking that but it is really
confirming my dedication to do that I
think that we've got an evil justice
system that needs to take into account
modern neuroscience another concepts we
talked about here so thank you all for
helping me come around to that and my
other thought which I mentioned the
beginning that I could change my mind
about the value of bringing a lot of
smart people together and a lot of cool
things come from that haven't changed my
mind
it really can happen so it's been really
great meeting all of you and up then a
pleasure to have been able to facilitate
it and thank you for your patience with
my in my naivete
you